arriving at berlin's hauptbahnhof there
are staff on the ground to assist k
macquarie when alighting
the station also has a system of
elevators taking passengers up and down
to local transport options
kay is a regular visitor to the german
capital
they come in getting around berlin is
okay
i can take the train the subway or the
bus
the entire public transport network is
pretty accessible
you just need to get information ahead
of time about where you're getting on
and off
then you're all right
half of the city's more than 170 subway
stations are currently barrier-free
by 2020 that figure is set to be 100
percent
all buses in the city already boast rams
for wheelchair access
it's just one of the various disabled
friendly features that won berlin the
2012 access city award from the european
union it's a badge of honor for the
authorities
the eu examined cities across europe
that have done well on this front
and are making progress this award says
that berlin already has a good setup it
also serves as an incentive and an
obligation to continue improving
that doesn't just apply to
transportation an increasing number of
buildings have likewise adapted to
wheelchair
users the most prominent being the
reichstag and its visitor dome
away from the center the botanical
gardens offer wheelchair rental for
getting around
free of charge
and for the blind or partially sighted
there's a fragrance garden where you can
touch and smell the plants
berlin's world famous museums also cater
to wheelchair users
the neues museum for example and its
most famous resident
ancient egyptian queen nefertiti
there's a bronze replica of the bust for
those unable to witness her eternal
beauty with their eyes
the museum also has descriptions in
braille and you can even touch
some of the exhibits such as this stone
baboon sculpture
over three thousand years old
empire
for a number of years now all public
museums have been offering guided tours
specifically for the blind and the
visually impaired as well
are unbeaten how about tegel airport
carolina barrera from mexico is using a
special free service provided by the
regional public transport operator
around 80 staff are on hand to escort
visitors to their desired destinations
all you need to do is call one week in
advance
i need the service so that i can lead as
normal a life as possible
i have poor vision
people with a disability like me would
be unable to travel alone through the
city
without an escort like this
there are a variety of websites with
information on wheelchair access
mobidot was among the first it has a
free database
now comprising over 35 000 entries that
gives grades to buildings in berlin
according to accessibility
users can also refine their search
according to disability
mobidot has staff on the streets of the
real world to verify the disabled
friendly credentials of locations
it now also provides consultation for
specialists across
europe working in this field
has been accompanying this development
towards better accessibility in berlin
since 1992.
it's a very old project and has its
roots in self-help among disabled people
it's played an important role on the one
hand pushing the city to make
progress while at the same time
documenting the changes
the kreuzberg area of town is famously
hip
but not for the handicapped
this is not easy-going terrain for k
mcquarrie
here in kreuzberg often kids
feel alpha there's a lot of pre-war
housing and that always means stairs
i generally end up asking people for
help going up a couple of steps
i prefer going into stores that have no
stairs provided i can find them
beneath them
and he can find many of them with the
non-human help of wheel map
a free of charge cell phone app it keeps
track of wheelchair accessible locations
not only in kreutzberg but across berlin
and the whole of germany
as long as he's online k macquarie will
always be able to find a place to meet
friends